wenn es erneut zu einer großen koalition
in berlin kommt dann wird die afg die
größte oppositionspartei im deutschen
bundestag darüber möchte ich jetzt mit
der fraktionsvorsitzenden der afg
sprechen ich grüße sie alles weiter
guten morgen herr weidmann freuen sie
sich schon auf ihre neue aufgabe als
oppositionsführerin im bundestag
wir freuen uns natürlich außerordentlich
wir sind ja drittstärkste partei wir
sind damit fast 13 prozent gewählt
worden und als stärkste
oppositionspartei hätten wir das anrecht
auf den sprecherposten des
haushaltsausschusses der uns natürlich
ein großes anliegen ist auf der anderen
seite ist es für den wähler eher
suboptimal denn es wäre eine koalition
der großen parteien ein weiter
wurschteln des weiter so der
wahlverlierer der wahl im jahr 2017 gut
aber eine andere alternative als die
große koalition scheint es nicht zu
geben
sie haben noch eine weitere option und
das ist eine minderheitsregierung gut
aber die ist sicherlich nicht gewollt
aber warten wir es ab noch sind die
sondierung ja nicht in trockenen tüchern
sie sprachen es gerade an sie
beansprucht und schon auch den vorsitz
des haushalts und finanzausschusses im
deutschen bundestag
aber natürlich das ist es ein wichtiges
anliegen
vor allem weil dort auch die
rettungspakete freigegeben werden so wie
wir das in den letzten jahren gesehen
haben und wir wollen eben auch
vollständige transparenz schaffen
so ist es beispielsweise auch so dass
die zahlung deutschlands die abführung
an die eu abgeführt werden ohne dass es
im haushalt eben nachher ausgewiesen
wird und auch da wollen wir transparenz
schaffen
die gibt es bisher eben nicht wenn es
darum die euro rettungspakete geht was
genau haben sie dann vor
ja gut also die euro-rettungspakete
verstoßen ja ganz klar gegen die
europäischen verträge die vorsehen dass
kein euro staat für die schulden eines
anderen staates haften darf diese
verträge werden ja permanent gebrochen
seit jahren darum gibt es ja auch die
alternative für deutschland das ist
unser kers
thema und das haben wir uns auf die
fahnen geschrieben und dafür wollen wir
eben politik machen dafür wurden wir
gewählt
also dann werden wir gespannt sein was
da auf uns zukommt und welche anderen
ausschüsse interessiert sie noch dann
federführend zu übernehmen
das werden wir in der tat intern
besprechen
dieser nächste woche wir werden die
gremien besetzung intern vor besprechen
und das ergebnis werden wir dann auch
zeitnah mitteilen
sie werden dann als größte
oppositionspartei auch das erst
rederecht haben das heißt wenn also die
regierung zum beispiel in einer
bestimmten angelegenheit das wort hat
dann können sie gleich als afd darauf
antworten
was bedeutet das für sie das ist immer
sehr gut wenn man direkt darauf
antworten kann weil sie dann eine
lebhafte debatte haben
und das wiederum fördert die demokratie
und darum wurden wir ja auch gewählt
darum ist die wahl der alternative für
deutschland in den deutschen bundestag
eben auch ein gewinn für die demokratie
in deutschland das eben auch dinge
ehrlich debattiert werden und auch
fakten benannt werden und darauf freuen
wir uns ihrer zentralen themen ist ja
die flüchtlingspolitik aber genau dieses
thema wird ja jetzt auch ein zentrales
thema werden bei den
sondierungsverhandlungen wie groß ist
eigentlich da ihrer einschätzung nach
der unterschied zwischen ihnen der afg
und der csu in dieser frage sehr gut
also die csu ist anlässlich des der der
landtagswahl extrem nervös geworden weil
merkel ja eigentlich eine spd politik
gemacht hat die letzten jahre immer
weiter nach links gerückt ist das ist
für die csu extrem schädlich das haben
wir schon bei der bundestagswahl gesehen
dass die csu enorm viel stimmen an die
fdp verloren hat und jetzt natürlich
fleißig das original also unser
wahlprogramm ab schreibt um überhaupt im
bayerischen landtagswahlkampf zu
bestehen das ganze sind für uns aus
unserer sicht nebelkerzen
wir haben es ja schon gesehen auch die
csu ist letztendlich de facto gegen eine
grenzsicherung grenzkontrolle und wird
auch letztendlich beim familiennachzug
einknicken denn das will ja die spd auch
gerne haben
wir haben es gelesen in den
zurückliegenden wochen und monaten im
bundestag in der sache sind sie klar und
deutlich aber ihr stil von der afg im
bundestag ist bisweilen von einer
gewissen aggression aggressivität
geprägt werden sie das so weitermachen
oder werden sie möglicherweise ihren
stil auch versachlichen
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen diesen
angeblich aggressiven stil
das sehen sie an meiner person das sehen
sie aber auch an anderen abgeordneten
den kann ich nicht unterschreiben und
den sehe ich auch nicht ganz im
gegenteil in den gesamten plenardebatten
wird eine verbale aggression uns
gegenüber angeführt die teilweise
grenzwertig ist und die wir auch beim
bundestagsvizepräsidenten auch angemahnt
haben und da hoffen wir natürlich auch
von den anderen parteien allen voran von
der spd und von den linken und von den
grünen eine mäßigung im ton als zweite
vorsitzende der bundestagsfraktion des
deutschen bundestages der afd
ich danke ihnen für das gespräch vielen
herzlichen dank herr weidmann